ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show a legendary comedian Colin
Quinn joins us uh you have a new show
which we're going to give everybody the
link in the uh YouTube episode they
should go grab tickets to it uh you do a
new hour like almost every year which is
insane and always very good
thanks yeah this one's good and we were
just talking about the uh yeah how even
that show itself I'm gonna start
shifting away it's already starting to
get on my nerves I could always tell
when it's time to move on material wise
my throat starts to really get sore your
throat rejects the material yes and then
you gotta just film it and get it move
on yeah
I feel the same way my throat hijacks
all the material I do because I yell at
a lot of it so that's the other problem
yeah by the end of a tour like I
remember in Milwaukee the good people of
Milwaukee who are now punishing me
they're not buying tickets to the Pabst
Theater because I canceled a night at
The Improv and rescheduled it for a
weeknight because I had no voice the
people of Milwaukee have a long memory
they're being unreasonable because I
didn't have a voice and I called my
agent who's for the 400 pounds the
fattest agent in America and he goes
well just get a steroid shot and I go
yeah but if I if I project through it I
could still get polyps on my throat sure
so these agents don't care they just go
just get shot up with steroids right
right The Show Must Go On well what you
should be doing is
stop remember I told you about the guy
Gary Ramsey but here's the thing you
gave me this advice about yeah it you're
basically like change your whole life
this is so hard tell people what you
told me to do
to go to Gary Ram's evening
no you're dead but Colin it's so
complicated the whole process no it's
not it's the opposite of complication
can you explain it and let's see if it's
not it's the what it is it's basically
it's called out it's basically Alexander
technique what it is is instead of
misusing your throat where you get
polyps and you get hoarse and you can't
speak a lot you're speaking through your
lungs are in the back you're speaking
through your stomach your diaphragm
basically so every time you're about to
lose your voice you're relaxing your
tongue relaxing I could show it to you
in five minutes right now but go I'm
living proof I used to lose my voice all
the time and ever since I went to Gary
which is almost 20 years I could do like
three shows I never lose my voice I even
want my voice and my voice is a raspy
voice that you would lose immediately as
you know people have spent many years
saying why aren't you and Tim Dylan
doing father-son comedies I know because
now I look older that's what I mean
that's one of the reasons no no I look
it's brother no it's not the father but
you were explaining to me and then this
guy sent me an email and he seems like a
real good dude and I think I might have
spoke to him Gary I think I spoke to the
guy but it's like a whole breathing
technique I mean I'm looking for like a
lodge injury so simple it's simple how
would I do it how do I simpler than a
shot you'd go see him for an hour he'd
explain to you oh here's where you're
gripping and you're like oh I didn't
realize I was like every time I yell you
could still yell but every time I yell
I'm yelling through my throat instead of
through this is an Abbey this is a a
theater that you can use yeah so it's
it's just little things like for example
babies breathe when we watch a baby
breathe that's how we're supposed to
breathe so they exhale and the stomach
goes out we exhale I mean we inhale they
inhale us don't that right we inhale
pull our stomach in so it's all this
tightening that goes on it's really you
know it's I'm gonna sit down but it's an
hour it's an hour consultation yeah it's
not really a consultation it's more like
uh you're instructional it's yeah it's
just it's interesting he's really an
interesting and now you don't lose your
voice at all I did three shows when I
was doing Broadway I had three shows on
Saturday three only me an hour and 20
minutes on like 800 seats three for an
hour and 20 minutes each show I was
exhausted at the end of the day my
throat was fine never on voice rest you
know they go oh you do shows you have to
be on voice rest on the off days I was
never on voice rest my whole and I used
to lose my voice from seller sets in
front of 100 people wow so this is well
worth it to try to figure out this it's
the greatest he's the greatest is the
new show you have now which is called
small talk yeah you used to you always
do like big themes it was like sure
political the country's divided sure New
York the history of New York all these
big themes this one is this more like
the minutia of the way people relate to
each other no it's the big theme okay I
apologize no no it is small talk it is
about the minutia of the way people
relate to each other but it's uh it's a
big but it's a bit but it's big it's big
in the sense of how the language and how
everybody speaks today
um like they're being watched and
pretending they're not under
surveillance when they know they are at
all times by each other right
everybody's just everybody's worried
about uh government surveillance and
that's only a part of surveillance
apparently right so nobody hates Free
Speech more than we do yeah everybody's
a rat yes it's a culture of rats yes it
is I grew up in a town that was a little
Mafia town in Long Island we know I I
know that town
it's always a little Mafia town and Good
Fellas was about Henry Hill like an
island park and they all Sopranos was
about a guy who lived in Iowa they all
lived in it all those mob guys moved
from Ozone Park to Island Park yeah they
all went to this little South Shore town
yep but yeah everybody's like a nice
boat they would love it was about
culture they love to be they love to be
around the boats yeah that's the thing
and the water yeah they like to come out
like flip-flops in those days it would
wear the brown socks with the right you
know with the slippers and yeah and then
just stand there and just smoke a cigar
with a miserable look on their face and
look out over the water yeah and that
was the the sign that they had made they
had moved from the city that's right and
but it that was a town where it was like
there was just this idea that you you
you minded your business yeah yeah I
didn't like any like we weren't like in
the mob clearly but you still just there
was a value to like minding your but
even with your opinions about other
people were kind of private right guys
we get your ass kicked yeah or you just
wouldn't you wouldn't open your mouth
about something you didn't know about
really because you didn't know who was
listening that's right but now that's
all over like those mob guys
they rat on everybody no one kills them
and they get like reality shows well I
tell you yeah I have a thing in my show
about how they have podcasts they all
have podcast friends all the mafia has
been it's horrible I mean it's a good
podcast though are they really you ever
listen to any of those I feel like they
get old after absolutely Clips yeah
right I mean after a while it's like we
get it yeah but that whole so your show
is like basically looking at this thing
that's happened where everybody is kind
of ready to pounce on everybody else
yeah well no yeah it's more yeah it's a
lot of it's a lot to do with small talk
and and the lack of small talk and what
it means in the big picture what's Small
Talk meant for communication which
eventually leads to podcasts and you
know it's communication that's what it's
about but it's about small talk yes
everything you do is always it's it's
always worth it because you're one of
those Comics who like you actually write
and you write the whole show is written
and rewrite all this you don't have to
do that now like most people now are
just kind of doing crowd work I don't
know if you know that but they ask
people where they're from or right how
long they've been [__] the person
next to them right you choose to write a
whole show about a topic why do you
commit yourself to that doesn't that
feel like a dying art well this show has
a little bit of crowd work because I
talk to people in small talk right like
I give examples and I ask people I make
them be in my conversation okay so I'm
not really asking them questions gosh
it's more like me making them interact
with me in a small town yeah scenario so
but um it is a dying art but you know
what I'm a dying man I mean what am I
here what am I 25 I mean you know it's
fine I know yeah but you're good yeah
the heart attack but you're back I had a
heart attack everything's great yeah
everything's I wouldn't say everything's
great but I would say everything's uh
it's just good it's good yeah it's a
solid but in the grand scheme as I was
telling Frank before for the show yeah
um I was saying in an Ideal World stand
up I'd rather do like the thing we were
working on like I'd rather direct I'd
rather write and direct then just text
well a certain point you hear your voice
and I'm like am I still talking we were
pitching a movie and then one of the
women on the pitch had like blue hair
and I went this might not go well you I
I knew from the beginning there was
something weird going on there they no
here's why I knew it was a problem
because the people on the pitch I could
tell they were like hey they dragged a
couple of interns and go we want you to
sit there and listen to this pitch right
and they're like oh okay and they're
just sitting there like wait we don't
belong here we don't know what's going
on we're not in trouble we're not The
Gatekeepers no it didn't we're going to
get coffee one of them holding a tray of
coffee that they're supposed to give to
them right and then they're like okay
and then we did the pitch I was like
this no they just didn't seem super
interested because it's subtle it's
Irish it's a great idea we had a great
idea for a movie and they didn't they
weren't into it it was about an Irish
family and when did we pitch that
two years ago maybe two and a half years
two years ago it could have been three
years three years ago there was not a
huge appetite for a story about an Irish
family
as shocking as it seems today we're
playing Netflix and we want we have a
story about an Irish family and they
looked at us like we said we wanted to
do like something we wanted to do like a
teen comedy about the Charlottesville
March like they were like they were like
this is not fit yeah I know and it's
crazy because you know it was it was
really you could you could see where it
was going to go it was going to be
really interesting I think maybe it's
gonna be funny things are changing
though maybe this you know who knows in
the future something might that would be
great I mean it's still the same you're
still the same character we're still the
same and we're gonna have Tim Dillon
because this is why Gary Ramsey came in
handy Yeah Tim was going to be the lead
singer in a bar band also so you get to
hear that Tim Dylan singing I mean would
that not have been fun it's funny
already yeah funny already and Netflix
in their Infinite Wisdom said no yeah
but um yeah everybody's just you know we
were crazy to try to do it that way but
here's what let me ask you this yeah in
in the ideal world since you seem to
have more of a business Acumen than I
ever will I don't but well well I think
you did you had to get a real job for a
minute
well real the FBI would characterize it
as um
a uh an issue but yeah yeah yeah it's
not yeah I mean you know everybody's a
Monday Morning Quarterback including the
feds
who do you think they you know they got
mortgages
but I mean many of the companies I work
for were rated good boy they were they
people did come in and want files Again
country of rats
it's like yeah
I just love the idea of like you're such
an Irish guy that like just because I
had a suit on once you're like you went
you had a real job it's like I worked in
a subprime mortgage Boiler Room like
yeah he had a real job
your boss went to jail
but yeah so I business acumen
so you know we talk about how people
like now everybody's a small businessman
yeah like my generation didn't really
understand until recently like when you
guys understood which is like oh I'm on
my own yeah I'm a small businessman I'm
a I'm a small business yeah my
everything you do has to be generated
out of this business a hundred percent
so I we didn't have a court we caught on
late of course because I was from a
different time but in in a world
theoretically if you had a movie right
yeah I'd say we had this movie we're
gonna make this movie right
what would you do to one raise the money
to
let the people at least have a chance to
get their money back because you can't
just get people to give money some
stupid GoFundMe thing where they're not
getting their money back why to be to
have your name at the end of a list of
80 names and credits so what would you
theoretically do I don't even you
probably shouldn't even tell me because
it's not somebody else will end up doing
it but you know what I mean you'd have
to kidnap Joe Rogan's dog or something
and then get you know what I mean like
cat I was gonna say you would kidnap our
Chrysler's family but that wouldn't that
would have been like Ransom of the Red
Chief where but but even bird Chrysler
Joe Morgan he would have been like no
I'm like I'm gonna kill your family give
me money Bird's gonna go all right no
Tuscaloosa we're going to Ohio see you
in Grand Rapids I love Helix mattresses
I have them and everybody loves them
when they visit my home my family is
coming to visit my home on the fourth of
July I'm not really excited about that
they're very judgmental we haven't seen
each other in a long time but they're
all going to love the mattresses uh
everyone loves them even the pets how
you know which Helix mattress works best
for you and your body take the Helix
sleep quiz and find out what's your
perfect mattress in under two minutes so
you just basically go to their website
you take a quiz Are you a side sleeper
back you know how it is everybody's
unique and sleeps differently that's why
Helix has several different mattress
models to choose from each design for
specific sleep positions and and feel
preferences and if your spine needs some
extra TLC they got you every Helix
mattress has a hybrid design combining
individually wrapped steel coils in the
base with premium foam layers on top the
foam is what's nice it's a perfect combo
of comfort and support
so now we're going to tell you the promo
code
just
Helix is offering 20 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to Helix sleep.comd this is
their best offer yet and it won't last
long helixsleep.com
Tim D with Helix better sleep starts now
um but I'm saying let's say even Joe
Rogan or Bird crush yeah if they gave
you the money yeah how would they get
their money back that problem is getting
the money here's the problem of movies
they cost so much [__] money yeah
they do and distribution's weird because
people aren't buying things online the
way they used to people are used to
subscribing to things like HBO GO or
Netflix or right Paramount they're not
used to an individual purchase the way
they would be you know maybe 10 years
ago the way they bought bought music on
iTunes now they have apple music which
is a subscription that's one of the
problems with it because you can't know
how many people will buy something and
you can't know how you're going to make
your money back I think the hope would
be that after you made the movie you
would have it you would license it to a
Hulu Netflix something like that yeah
but that's depressing it's very
depressing I mean some you know
licensing it's like you do all the all
this stuff and then the investors and by
the way investors always they it's hard
for them to get their money back once it
turns into those machines and that's the
other problem you don't want to screw
people out of their money like it's
difficult because everybody because like
with podcasts people have proven they
could do late night shows on their own
they go oh I can basically do and get
the audience at Kimler Fallon or Colbert
gets
um with sketches online people have
proven they can do a version of what SNL
does that's right I can make comedy
sketches people can you know digest them
and and love them and subscribe to other
things I'm doing
but with movies and similarly with
episodic TV it's very very difficult you
can't make a succession on your own you
can't make a Game of Thrones on your own
these are difficult these are massive
big budget Productions with hundreds of
people top-notch Talent
um it's difficult that's why those
companies still dominate that particular
uh genre of entertainment but I don't
think that's why because
secession Game of Thrones are great but
when you're making when they're making
it's because they promote what they want
and they have the power to control what
people say that's right so for example a
movie like Mean Streets from 1973 at
that time a little boy God knows what
the budget was then right but that kind
of quality
you can't just buy they can't make those
they don't understand how to make a
funny movie of that John they don't
understand so I'm just saying you can
make in my opinion funny movies that are
low budget because we're not trying to
Dazzle them with visual low budget but
you gotta wonder how you get your money
out of it that's what I'm saying that's
the question that's how I started this
conversation right you know I don't know
why suddenly acting like you're asking
me no no no it's hard I thought this no
you're right I don't have an answer Oh I
thought you did because of the mortgage
thing if 20 000 people buy a movie for
ten dollars that's not enough
50 000 people buy it for ten dollars
that's five hundred thousand dollars
that's nothing so now a hundred thousand
people buy it for ten dollars that's a
million dollars and that's a lot of
people knowing right it's still not
enough let me tell you so let's say you
had a movie okay theoretically let's say
at a movie like one of my movies you
Christa Stefano
Andrew Schultz right yeah so you guys
are in this movie yes now you will
promote it on your podcast as part of
the thing yeah that's where we go for
promotion No One's Gonna help No One's
Gonna Come on and then you go on other
people's podcasts because they're like
why wasn't i in it right
um so they give you a little passive
aggressive yeah so it's you three guys
promoting how much how many people do
you think you get to buy it it's the big
question mark because right it's a big
question mark because you could look at
all the numbers and say
it should be a certain percentage of the
amount of people you have
but you don't know until it's out there
right and how it's received
well yeah it has to be great last would
be great and people have to love it and
it's got to connect and people have to
buy it and they have to keep watching it
and keep talking about it it's like all
of that's tough It's hard to know
whereas if like people buy ads based on
a podcast when they go let's say this
guy's got a million or two million
listeners a percentage of them will
click the link and buy the product you
could try that with a movie and say well
the if all add up all the listeners they
have or fans they have or look at ticket
sales look whatever look at email lists
still who buys it that's the big
question but that's the other thing
because look what I did I did cop show
right cop show yes was internet thing
funny really for everybody I did
everything right it was all funny every
episode's funny all got all these
celebrities at the time to be in it
every episode it's still no eyes right I
mean it was unbelievable because it's
difficult even though something can be
quality yeah it's very hard to get it
like right now the biggest things that I
that I saw go viral were things that
were initially things that people like
hated or did it like little Nas acts
that's on Old Town Road but it's kind of
like it came out it was kind of like a
joke then people were like hey it's kind
of catchy it's actually kind of good
then he became massively famous a lot of
things start as like this like I would
think if we did a movie like this right
we'd have to come up with a marketing
campaign and this is where you go to
Schultz because he's brilliant with
stuff like this
um and we could all figure it out but
you'd have to come up with a marketing
campaign where the people
hot like Blair Witch Project came out
people like is this found footage is
this real right maybe it is now
obviously No One's Gonna think that's
not the angle we use because we're all
known as comedians we still have to find
the marketing angle and Burke Chrysler
is brilliant with this too that really
gets eyeballs on this thing right that's
the challenge that's hard it's you you
put all the work like every comedian
you know you put a lot of it into the
thing you're doing sure but then there's
a whole other which I'm okay at I'm not
nearly as good as other people there's a
whole other job
of getting people to see it yeah
figuring out how I would get hire the
trans girl that Dylan Mulvaney from Bud
Light yes I'd hire her yeah I would hire
Dylan Mulvaney to promote the film in
the most grotesque way
I don't even like Bud Light she's just
there with the can and she's gone I love
beer I would have her talking about I
would have her beating her dick with a
hammer yeah just to get attention yeah
just to get any attention you need to
kind of do something like that
controversial people gotta be angry yeah
they gotta be mad it's a it's a it's a
whole different thing yeah cop shows
just a really funny good thing yeah
that's tough you're right people have to
be angry they have to kind of be enraged
well what about this yes we get during
the when we're filming right we have a
camera that's a rogue Renegade camera we
have nothing to do with it right one of
the cameraman's just crazy right and he
catches de Stefano and Dylan Mulvaney
like blowing each other and that's
believable yeah yeah it's perfect and uh
back behind the scenes and then two days
later when people get bored of that we
have seven are trying to strangle Dylan
Mulvaney right he's gonna hit her too
that makes sense yeah there's gonna be
violence as well because we were gonna
do it yeah yeah it's not a bad idea and
she'd be up for it we'd call her agent I
mean she'll do anything and but it needs
to be something like that as much as we
could
without that type of controversy people
it's just because there's so much [__]
out there now that's what it is YouTube
is so big my uncle just watches fishing
yeah on YouTube yeah there are people
and he just watches that yeah he just
watches it like to get to him
you have to get that you have to somehow
puncture that Community the bass boat
Community someone there has got to go
this movie's really funny like
everybody's in their own micro Community
right now I'm speaking of fishing shows
my last sketch at SMI before let's say I
wrote this sketch I I was in it it was a
fishing show that was based on uh we
bring in Tracy Tracy's like Brock Peters
in um you know the movie from 1916. yeah
whatever it's called Uh
what's that what's the thing that
famously did a play
it's like the big movie of the racial
thing from 1916. um the the med greevers
thing no no it was like the it was a
giant play with Jeff Daniels
um to kill a mockings Kill a Mockingbird
yeah so is it so I'm there I'm like hi
welcome to the fishing show and Tracy
comes in I go I understand you walk by
Miss so-and-so's house and you looked in
the window he goes I did not so and we
did this whole sketch it was like this
one of these scenes Jim Bruce ended
playing like redneck Sheriff right and
Daryl's in it as the father and it was
one of the funniest things they cut it
after dress it was a little dicey
probably yeah but the girl was Britney
Spears like 18 years old and she was
great in it by the way that's amazing it
was really funny do you still have it I
don't I don't know how I can get a hold
of the car probably they probably burned
it what was your favorite thing you did
on that show
uh doing the the lion up at the
beginning I did this Lion character it
was like a drug lion yeah first was on
with no one where I was like let me get
an update doing that stuff and then once
sitting next to Bill Murray and it was
like you know by the time I was there it
was the 90s people had a different
mentality like everything was you wanted
to do well Bill Murray went on there and
just did what Bill Murray used to do
which was this Bill Murray's tone was
never heard before he did it in the
1978. nobody ever saw this tone in
comedy just like Richard belts Richard
Bell's a stand up was not that great but
nobody he invented okay babe sure nobody
did that before I never saw it and then
people in the streets were doing it not
just Comedians and Bill Murray used to
go like now listen to me guy and he had
this ironic weird thing he did these
characters like this movie review it was
just a whole different tone than you'd
ever seen in comedy or in life how many
people have you seen do that like where
they have where they're completely
unique
um I can't think of that many I mean
those are those I mean I would say Bill
Murray chained like everybody was funny
in different ways and they were all
unique on Saturday Night Live to a
degree but Bill Murray I'll tell you
another one I haven't seen even though
it's based on something real but it's
it's that guy Tom on succession right
that's unique yeah toned that you don't
see the English actor McFadden yeah he's
brilliant he's doing these crazy guy
right that's like it's completely you've
never seen a character quite like that
but Bill Murray did like five characters
on on SNL at that time he did the ship
like that cruise like you know people
always make fun of like this Lounge
singer the oily Lounge singer right he
nobody did that before him right nobody
did it with that tone the way he used to
do it and I feel like Norm had that
space yeah nobody perfect example right
Norm's tone was distinctive and unique
yes and nobody did that nobody did what
Norm did you know what I mean I talk
about Norm in the show too it's funny
but and one of the things is normally
talk people like we talked to some
strange way you know small talking
people and be like and then the guy like
you're right I'm quitting a job and he'd
walk out and then nobody go to me I
didn't tell him to quit that job like
yes you did but he like Norm's whole
world was not just me he was making fun
of you you were part of this the suckers
too yeah yeah you'd be like I mean
you're telling me you know he was just
spring you and it's that brilliant
podcast he had with Adam me again yes
yeah well I went to Norm's uh uh
you know his uh memorial service yeah
Anatomy get spoke and he killed it was
all these professional experience he had
to be coming up and he goes I love Norm
Macdonald even though if you Google me
today it says Holocaust Den iron Adam
Egan that's the first thing
and he went on about normal yeah it was
perfect because the guest didn't know
that uh like half the gas nowhere to go
I mean I agree with you not like this
guy thinks the Holocaust didn't happen
and they guess if he look you could see
the Angry Eyes like what and Adam would
just sit there and take it and the guest
would leave the show thinking this guy's
a holocaust denied
yeah there was nothing funnier than when
Norm yeah was like yeah this guy [__]
this is the Holocaust happen so fun and
just blow past it and the guest would
look you could see them looking and then
Norm would move on yeah brilliant yes
Norm would just keep going and then yeah
would you sneak a look at him like what
the [__] yeah and it was an Adam to his
credit didn't sometimes you try to deny
it usually just take the hit yeah that
person that's so funny have you gone
down to Rogan's Club Adam's running that
club and uh no I haven't been there yet
yeah he texted me I don't know what
happened I'm supposed to do it you
should go check it out I want to do it
of course yeah it's great it's designed
by a comic you feel it when you're oh it
is yeah
yeah a comic's known for their good
interior design I'm sorry well no she's
not a good interior designer but like
the way the rooms are felt right like
the way the the spacing yes the the
crowd like where they are where you are
on stage like it's all perfectly done oh
I gotta love it I don't know that we
need all the UFO imagery it's still it's
a lot of UFOs That's Heavy on the UFO
imagery but he likes that but it is
perfect in terms like ratio comedy-wise
that's great yeah I can't wait to do it
did you ever do anything with Woody
Allen I feel like that's such a New York
guy and you're such a New York guy and
yeah I was in um I was in two Woody
Allen there's two Woody Allen stories
that are quick I'm quick to take an hour
but
um a podcast I know it is you guys it
doesn't know but one was I got in a
movie in 1987 I got in a movie uh New
York stories Woody Allen's doing a movie
him fox say yeah I remember that so I
played a cop I had a few lines so here's
how what it arrogant and just annoying
person this call Tom was 6 30 a.m so I'm
doing comedy at night I'm smoking three
packs a day
so first day I show up 9 30 on the set
my trailer
these the second a day starts screaming
at me what is your problem this is a
Woody Allen movie everyone yeah but you
haven't even gotten to me yet she goes
you don't know that you don't know
anything you just you know you've done I
was like all right whatever she goes you
better show up this is Woody Allen next
day I show up 8 30. 6 30 call two hours
late she's like what's your problem
for this movie you can you know in those
days you couldn't there's no cell phone
they didn't have a number phone I didn't
answer my phone
um so I show up again they didn't use me
again by the way third day I show up
like 7 45 6 30 course she's not even mad
she's actually pleased that's how you
train people's minds yes so she was like
huh okay and she hates me but she's
Beyond she's you know second ad all they
do is work they sleep one hour a day for
the whole shoot yeah finally they get to
my scene we do the scene with Union
Square Park I and I'm thinking I'm in a
Woody Allen movie but I suck at the time
I didn't understand anything about
acting and so they cut the scene I was
playing a cop with his mother and I'm so
bad you could see it in the actresses I
was like oh this guy doesn't I don't
know did Woody communicate how yes he
told me an acting he goes okay just do
this and I was like oh Woody Allen's
directed me I didn't realize that any of
the insight to realize wouldn't know
Woody Allen's trying to save the scene
and he realizes there's a problem in a
dead weight called this guy playing the
cop and it was he it was nice he was
kind very nice but I mean you know
I was a little older so yeah right I
mean his motives was just pure right
um but the uh but then so then like
15 years later this guy named Ray Garvey
who's a
cop who also ran comedy clubs anyway but
in Brooklyn Pips you know Pepsi old
comedy club which I have a couple of
stories about if you want those two but
anyway Pips was the this old New York
comment it was it's older than the
Improv it's gone where was it Sheepshead
Bay wow and it's older than the Improv
it was the first comedy club in New York
City right so anyway this guy ragoff
he's running he goes hey Colin you know
you want to do uh I'm doing a film with
Woody Allen's gonna do stand-up and then
he'll bring you on stage like oh Woody
Allen's been offered millions of dollars
to do stand up Ray he's not coming out
to Brooklyn to you and doing stand-up
comedy
a month later Woody Allen's doing
stand-up in a film being filmed and then
brings and now Colin Quinn
I go on stage
I mean Woody Allen was doing stand up in
the film he got what he allowance to do
stand up right God isn't he does Jazz
right and he actually got up they did a
few jokes and then brought me on and but
everybody's there that day you know it's
like all of Brooklyn like this is right
before Sopranos so it's like yeah Danny
Aiello Pat Cooper and first Danny Aiello
pulls in he's got the Jaguar he drives
in his Jaguar then they go all right now
in this scene you move it you come in
driving in the car he goes wouldn't you
want me to use my jaguar in the scene
and they're like okay yeah you're right
there so he drives his Jaguar to the
scene just then Pat Cooper Falls up
across the street so I know them all
they're all and I and Pat gets out of
his car and goes what they send a Jaguar
for Danny Aiello and I gotta get a town
car he starts screaming he's mad they
calm him down he goes on after me and
Woody Allen does imp does improv a half
hour of the most brilliant yeah free
association just riffing on the room
ripping on everybody
and then finishes I mean literally 25
minutes people are crying right and then
Woody's in the audience so everybody's
laughing he's busting what are these bus
average balls and then they go okay Pat
now we're gonna do turn around so we
need you to do that again Woody's got to
go buy Woody thank you for coming when
he leaves they go now we got to get you
speaking Pat
he goes what they go well we had to get
we had to get Woody before he left in
the audience so you want me to um do
what I just did that brilliant uh off
the cuff ad-lib you want me to do that
now and you're gonna do it with me and
they go yeah he goes what oh yeah that's
that's fine you just another 25 just me
doing what I and they go Pat don't be
like because hey you know what
[__] Woody Allen [__] Ray Garvey [__]
this whole [__] production is never
gonna be [__] [__] you oh [__] this
is what people told me about my whole
career and he goes bad [__] and he
leaves and he leaves and he goes to
randazzos which is a big Clam Bar yeah
this is right next to the best Pips was
about 80 feet from random that's
calamari and sauce in the world the
greatest yeah so it's that's it's
probably like 50 yards from okay but now
I know exactly where it is
yeah so um
so then we're all over there at
Randazzles and Jackie motley's trying to
combat that he's involved too yeah
everybody's doing your poorly walnuts
was there everybody was you know just
all these New York people at that time
you know and then they said Pat you
gotta relax he goes don't tell me to
[__] relax Jackie he's screaming all
the customs and laughing like oh God
group is happening meltdown yeah because
and it was really funny and um yeah so
that was the that was the time those are
my two Woody Allen stories and that was
the oldest Club in the city yeah and you
started comedy what year
like 84 I guess middle 84. and you were
starting it at at Pips and places like
that
well I'll tell you the great pip story
so I go to Pips to audition I'm from
Brooklyn I think I might have been there
once as an audience member because I
used to be around that neighborhood
sometimes that was like a hot neighbor
that was like the Brooklyn fun
neighborhood where you go they had a
place called Captain Walters a place
called wheelers it was like a little fun
place to go to but anyway so I go to
Pips I'm going to audition and I go
there it's Wednesday's audition night so
I get there places close I get there
early like I always get a place and
there's a sign pasted to the outside on
a piece of loose leaf paper you know
Joey Lim Buco won't be here tonight I'm
like oh don't think anything of it
finally they open I Walk In audition
happens there's like eight of us 12
audience members whatever seven people
in the crowd nobody in the crowd I get
up to audition
six Italian Guys from from Avenue X at
the time Avenue X was was a famous place
in those years with
yeah just the wife beaters tattoos
shaved heads they're all wearing shaved
heads at something yeah probably 84.
maybe 85. and oh [__] and they come in
start throwing chairs around
everybody get the [__] out of here to
show his audition right to remember my
audition Jesus Christ the show's over
the show's outside Oh Come See Joey
limpuck whatever his name was don't see
this [__] they're [__] so I get off
stage I stand next to the owner because
I'm like I'd rather get my ass kicked
and at least be able to work the clock
work the club you know how it is right
you're addicted so I'm like yeah [__] it
you know like [__]
and he's like you guys he didn't pay
turns out the guy auditioned the week
before on Wednesday that's why they're
back on Wednesday right their friend joy
limpu and didn't pass
interesting so now they go they just
want to shoot a quick comedy they chase
the crowd out there's a guy in a flatbed
truck Joey's up there on the flatbed
truck doing his act
and these guys are like yeah Joey and
he's like yeah you ever crack somebody
in the [__] side and they're like
yeah they're laughing like here's why I
should have quit comedy he's like four
audience members four audience members
out of the people who just saw them go
crazy go around the truck and start
watching and laughing
like okay the show's out here
some people they're sheep they don't
care
truck on Evans Avenue yeah I know
they're like okay Show's out here now at
least we're not paying for our drinks
right they're just laughing at him like
okay this is funny yeah but um but the
only thing was I got an audition because
I stuck with the owner they let me go on
that Friday night but I bombed you know
suddenly didn't use me anymore so then
it's 1984. yeah and you start and and
the city's dangerous then yeah it's a
different city yeah and the mafia
controls these clubs some of them now oh
yeah I'm sure they ran Pips I'm sure
they ran everything on him and said
right and then you're just trying to
feed who are the biggest comedians that
you're looking at when you're starting
um was it Jerry was it Jerry was already
big Jerry's probably the biggest
um and then
um all the casualizing Star Comics were
big but so who are they but it depends
who's been like big with in within the
comedy community right not big like
audience wise but the big ones that we
all were like oh Rich Jenny yeah Rich
Jenny was considered like he was working
all these Rogue gigs and he was like the
man you know yeah there was a guy named
Ronnie shakes I don't know if you've
ever heard of him he was on The Tonight
Show like five times it's so funny he
goes yeah he'd do all one line and he
goes I um
I tried to uh commit suicide once uh by
Drowning myself in the ocean I don't
know how serious I was I brought a towel
so you know jokes
he had a bunch of jokes like that and he
was kind of big and um you know Eddie
Murphy just blown up I was bought any of
the comic strip so Eddie Murphy would
come in once every six months right and
like and just go on to it was crazy you
know right but um yeah I mean I don't
know who was that big Richard Lewis was
big back then
um you know Larry David around yeah but
he wasn't a great guy he wasn't he was a
funny always but he wasn't like some
like he would get mad at the audience in
two seconds I actually was there one
night when it was uh
Lenny Dykstra and his friends Yeah Wendy
Williams and them and Larry David got
into this big old mat for the mats yeah
and then him and Larry David not Lenny
but his friend okay some drunk in front
of his and then they're leaving and the
friend is going you [__] Jew you Jew
bastard and then Gilbert godfreed was
crying with laughter and just spent like
an hour going aha Joe bat like he just
loved that the friend did you know Larry
back in the day yeah but I mean I know
was he kind of like an ornery guy or no
he was in that he was a he was a he was
an ornery but he was not unfriendly to
community no he was a nice guy he just
was I want to reach the audience right
so like his opening here's how he would
test the audience I mean it was not fair
to them and I believe me yeah being fair
to them is not high my priority right
but he would go uh hello it's good to be
here I'll use the two form with you
people because I feel I know you well
enough to use the two form rather than
the Vu form so unless you took like
friend in [__] high school right how
would you know that right and then if
they didn't let me like you [__]
[__] later you turned the crowd very
quickly he was ready to just throw down
but he was always funny right like even
to us he was funny who were the was it
was it like uh the female cop was like
Nancy Parker Serita rudners she had a
huge residency in Vegas yeah and she had
funny jokes you know what I mean yeah
like oh it's old she was great it was
Joan Rivers around or not really no
those people would this was like a new
thing I think they must have been like
what the hell's happening right but
Rodney would come in right Rodney would
come in and he was this is a
he wouldn't go to his own club speaking
of mob he would go coming to catch and
he'd show up in his bathroom with a
Heineken and go on stage for 10-15
minutes and he was
so just he was a real comedian like he
had talked to Comedians and bus balls I
used a lot of them for openings yeah and
you know you could try to sell them
jokes I try to sell him a few jokes and
he's like all right kid no no no that's
okay you know my jokes was her shitty
and uh and then some you know I'm trying
to tell him like whatever and um
and uh some lady I remember once coming
up to him going Randy Rodney you don't
get no respect he was okay lady okay go
[__] yourself okay
oh my God
but he was just a he was a funny guy he
was the only real celebrity that would
come in yeah and then how did everything
like when when your SNL was like because
you were doing a bunch of stuff that was
later on that was mostly I was on MTV
right that was my big that was my thing
SNL that's right that's when I would
really like if there was a time that
would have been the time for me to blow
up it would have been I was I would go
to a college and it'd be 1500 people
lined up I go what show are they waiting
for I think I would laugh like what did
it he goes no that's for you and I was
like holy [__] that's when college kids
watch TV I wasn't prepared yeah nobody
over we would walk around the streets me
and Ken the house
any we would get swamped like
there's kids screaming and nobody over
23 knew what the hell who the hell it
was really interesting yeah things were
so delineated you know right right it
would just cut off Ben actually that was
the 90s yes that was I remember watching
yeah on the on that show in the 90s yeah
and that's what when did you meet Adam
and those guys was it at SNL no I met
Adam I met Adam when he was 17. before
before MTV I knew him on MTV too and but
I met him in 1984-85 he was 17 and he
was just coming around with this little
crew of guys and he was this kid from
NYU that was just you know a charismatic
he already had his his crew of the guys
he still works with today wow and yeah
it was really interesting you know and
he was he just immediately obvious how
insanely talented he was no first time I
saw him I was like this kid's yeah he's
he's he's cocky but he's not really
funny but right and then he went on the
road for six months and he came back
just on the road by himself did his
worked all these [__] gigs did wherever
he went and I came back and I was like
this is a star right just funny you know
I mean he was always a Charming cocky
guy but when he came back from that road
I was like yeah boy yeah that's the
beauty of the road like you know right
the beauty of Comedy which no other art
has I feel like is the audience without
the audience editing and helping you and
throwing cold water and going that's not
funny we're here to laugh sorry you
could be as CLE we don't get it without
that that's that's what we have that
nobody else has we have that feedback
that's immediate if feedback that's
immediate and honest it's not it's
involuntary laughter right right so even
if a musician is out there if I go to
see a band I like I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna be like I don't know what to tell
them is raw you're not gonna yell out in
the middle of their new song this isn't
working this yeah this part is dragging
you need to check right but when you're
silent you're telling the people we're
not laughing right now right and you're
like oh well they came here to laugh
they like me they want to laugh if
they're not laughing I can pretend it's
something else but it's ultimately I'm
not gonna get a left there unless I fix
that so when he came back from that time
on the road you were like this is it was
only six months right he came back and
he was so funny and so charismatic
funny as hell and just had his he just
became himself by the time he was 18 19
he was just
he had that he had that sting that thing
where people just you had to love him
you had to love him he was just funny
cocky but in a nice way and just had it
right
it's like certain people you watch like
we watch you know I'll I'll still listen
to Patrice on Ona you know oh my God and
obviously watch all of his specials but
when you you know you listen to him on
on a the way he would break something
down nobody yeah that's right nobody can
do that
you know that's why he did it nobody
that's correct and that's what I think I
guess the best compliment is is that
this is a one and done this person's
perspective is that's it yeah and it's
and it's yeah and it's also the tone and
even on tough crowd Patrice on tough
crowd which I didn't even notice as much
at the time as much as I loved what he
was doing but he would just go
and you and you knew okay for the next
three everybody's trying to speak and
get their thing in this son of a [__]
would stop and say okay and it almost
his body language would move back
now we're gonna listen me for [__]
three well however long I decide this is
right and if you look at stand up
the people a lot of successful stand-ups
are doing a tone of you're going to
listen to me however long it's going to
take interesting right yeah that's
probably true
and then a lot of people yeah and and I
I'm always amazed at how like
when people get into that zone that
Patrice was in
every topic he talked about he owned it
uh only exactly what I'm saying right
own dead yes yeah yes yeah because for
whatever reason when he was he's one of
these people he'd speak about something
and then suddenly well look what do you
think you what do you think your podcast
is popular because you'll start talking
about something and then you'd be people
be like oh I know where this is going
and then suddenly it goes to a turn and
you're like what why are you going in
that door that's the unique that's what
tone is yeah it's some it's all people's
minds that's what makes things
interesting yeah I mean I know you don't
like a compliment being Irish but
um I could just see like stuff I've
lived in California long enough I'm an
Arab
actually I'm uh you know yeah I forgot
how everybody dressed in the city
everybody's in monochromatic uh you know
blues and blacks right and you know I I
have you know color I got yeah salmon
shorts and uh I just you know I forgot
that New York everybody's just like
invested in this uniform of misery well
I feel like it's awesome I'm dressed
like a music manager in Miami who just
got my artist out of jail
and I'm like yeah my order is gonna be
it rolling loud but we had to get them
out of jail
and uh we're very excited I represent
shiggy the God who will be
shiggy had issues with his baby mom's
guy
um but you know it's all good gun wasn't
his he'll be it rolling loud on the
smaller stage 6 30 P.M
you know everybody come out
um yeah yeah it's it's it's crazy you
know you've been
like one of the most influential people
I think with comedy because you do it in
a way that people you know the one-man
show you were doing before a lot of
people did it sure and you're you do it
with jokes and a lot of people do it
without jokes a lot of people do without
them but that's the thing yeah if you're
not doing jokes right it's not coming
right to me if you're not eliciting
laughs that's not just however you do
that you do it but if you're not getting
laughs it's not stand-up comedy you can
call it something else but yeah it's not
stand up yeah that's the pride that we
want but the fun because I talked to
Louie recently and Louie's like maybe I
won't come back to it because Louie's
like done it all so like Louie's hit the
Heights and we'd all love him to come
back he's amazing but I mean he's done
everything there's you know yeah do you
ever feel like you you'll maybe one day
be it up or no because you just dive
into new topics all the time well I have
so much backed up material too that I
could do but uh but like I said I'd like
to take a few years and just write and
direct things I know just because like
yeah stand up I've been doing it so long
it's not like I'm at some high level I
mean I I'm out there humping when I go
when I go out on the road I can't you
know I'm not I'm selling a couple
hundred seats so it's not like I'm some
big act where I'm like oh this is crazy
I'm flying out I'm bringing my friends
with me that's not the way it goes right
so it's fine I'm just saying but that's
that's not the kind of Attraction but
have you ever thought of launching an
energy drink because your problem is you
spend all this time like writing the
jokes getting the perfect material oh
here's the great take on this that's not
what we're doing now I don't know if
you've taken a look at the uh landscape
well we're not doing that we're doing
more like energy drink I like that yeah
you know it's it's going in a different
direction do you do you maybe I'm still
do more music I'm still my I don't even
have merch I'm sorry I'm a merch the
instead of Comedy now you just take the
photos with the people you sell them the
shirts and you go on stage five ten
minutes
that's the way to do it yeah but it's
it's
I don't know idiot listen here's what
I'll say it's a weird
thing now because you know we're we're
all fighting for attention
Well everybody's always that's comedy
you're fighting your attention oh yeah
we all want people to go oh this
person's saying something funny on that
side of course right so we're all no
one's above it everyone has to do it
yeah I do it my crazy way I used to run
around with wigs and fake tits like yeah
people just you got to get attention
that's fine yeah yeah I mean like I said
as long as it's you know it's style and
substance not yeah not just style you
know as long as the silent substance but
if you have the choice style well that
was my mistake
silent substance but if you have to lose
one of them
you can what do you think about uh you
know you did such a your red state blue
state was so funny because it was about
this idea of a national divorce which is
actually like you said and jokes but
it's also everywhere now that like you
know you can read all of this stuff
right you know what people are talking
about it and it it's kind of interesting
you know this I I I advise anyone that
hasn't seen that to watch that because
it is funny about we've stopped seeing
the differences in each other
comedically that's right we don't see
them as funny we see them as threatening
yes and that's the the Prelude to
unfortunately what seems like a bad
situation that's correct because if you
can laugh at hey they're a little wacky
in the blue States and the red states
are wacky for their reasons right and
everybody has different Vibes and
everybody kind of laugh and nobody's
really forcing each other to do the
thing that the other one you know and
now it just feels like we're trying to
make this into a one-size-fits-all thing
and we can't laugh well that for what
you're describing first happened to
ethnicity and now in this country with
and I did New York story was one I bet I
got that one slipped that one under the
door right and now it's man now it's
about ideological things and it's just
and it's just the mo the people that set
the tone in my opinion because of social
media partially mostly is the most the
the zealots right and the extremists and
the people that are and that Zealot an
extreme nobody ever used this expression
this person was activist funny because
for a reason so these are the people
that set the tone right and even their
idea of humor is very you know it's what
I liked about red Saint Blue State you
broke down culture yeah and you talked
about not it was not a political show
it's not this it's not that you talk
about culture and how people differ yeah
and how environments differ yeah and how
you know people believe certain things
and thinks they're certain things
because of where they're from and how
they live yeah to flatten all of those
people and to make them all feel one way
is a Fool's errand yeah exactly and
that's yeah yeah it's gonna lead to the
blow up I mean Long Island and New York
are so different if you try absolutely
40 minutes to where I grew up it's
different than Manhattan so how in God's
name are you going to get central Texas
that's right on board with uh Tacoma you
just don't well and before you die
trying well and like true true what true
zealots do is they think that the the
people in that part of Long Island have
to change right the way they see things
they're wrong instead of going wait a
minute let's discuss this and find a way
but nobody can be a little bit of a Live
and Let Live yeah or at least a
compromise but the whole country's based
on compromise but apparently that's uh
it's not kind of it's gonna not gonna
fly in the future yeah it's a it's a
crazy if you I always say which is if
you if you're either if you characterize
people as either groomers or Nazis
there's not going to be a lot of wiggle
room right if you're at the point and
that's it that's all that is that we've
descended to the type of politics where
everyone either a pedophile or a Nazi it
is on the internet everybody's just
tweeting that yeah it is a good point
and true in full disclosure my brother
said it first right
yeah wait no my brother okay
he's not a comedian he just said it to
me one day yeah that's a good point he's
a great Point well thank you for
disclosing that because we would have
known no people would have said oh you
said that now then the rest of my life
would be like well my brother
my brother
um it's it's interesting and and this
new chat GPT and all the AI yeah and all
these computers that are going to
take over and everybody kind of is
cheerleading that I I think we lived in
the last time yeah of the thing that
we're doing being done the way we do it
yes I think things the digital World's
Gonna Win
or it's gonna be it's gonna be so
transformative that what we did was
unrecognizable yeah
um
but I'm glad I lived now yeah if
somebody said would you like to be two
years old now I'd say no I know I mean
who knew the Matrix that would be such a
yeah I mean even at the time people like
this Matrix is really amazing yeah but
now people like oh my God yeah this
sucks yeah but I I I'm glad that I kind
of occupied the time I did where I saw a
little bit of it yes but I had a lot of
before it became omnipresent where you
couldn't get away from it well it's
funny you said it because the the small
talk is about how personal how you won't
say I talk about that there needs to be
a museum because you'll not see these
personalities no again because of GPT
chat and all those other stuff all the
other stuff the whole algorithm and
it'll seem like it's being deep but
it'll be well we're now engine it we
have the ability to engineer people
that's right from their birth that's
right throughout their whole life and
they're much more connected to their
phone than they will be to their
Community that's right and to their
traditions and so those personalities
you would find all over the country that
differed greatly yes are gonna go away
and they're going to be replaced by this
kind of homogenized version exactly yeah
which will suck yeah but those are the
people that eventually and whatever the
next phase of right whatever that what
wolf just fall in line and be the
workers for whoever is running the show
yeah sadly yeah well it's all right
people already fall in line the way they
speak they speak in algorithms that's
what I want to talk about yeah yeah
that's interesting they speak in
algorithms yes that's it
yeah well it's fun stuff yeah real funny
but it's fun but it's Irish and you know
it's the you know Louis does that bit
all all good things and bad
and that's the Irish thing yeah
that's the thing about being Irish is
not really expecting like people that I
know that are really drunk on Hope yes
it's so antithetical to me just because
I was raised without it that's that's
right that's right I mean the Irish are
raised without yes there's no we don't
believe in that kind of thing we don't
believe enthusiasm and hope is just
disgusting it's gross people look at you
like you're just they're disgusted by it
no it's like the yeah there will be a
tomorrow but I mean God only knows what
the hell that's going to be like is that
right yeah good luck with that yeah
and it we do live in a time now where in
order to be super positive you have to
be a little bit of a sociopath
don't be a little bit I think it's
always been that time well that's
probably how it is yeah I mean to be
just completely like things are good
yeah yeah Colin Quinn where can people
get tickets
to this new show well when's it coming
out this is coming out today oh wow
thanks
it's a city geez I know harlequin.com I
mean that's really the way to go
colloquin.com you're in New York that's
the way to go that's the way to go
and then you're on the road and then I'm
on the road a little bit and then
hopefully by next summer I'll be
directing you outside of an Italian
restaurant in Island Park I mean we've
always wanted to make this movie about
Long Island I think it could be more of
a reality yeah I think so too now and
we'll see I mean there are what happens
yeah there are things that are good
there are you know positive I just got
my I I don't want to say what was done
to me but I just did a horror movie I
just did another really big movie I had
a small scene the director yelled at me
a lot I don't know if it's in the movie
but it's with one of the biggest stars
in the world and maybe it will be in the
movie but the director seemed very
unhappy with me but at the end he said I
meant my wits end with you but at the
end but at the end he said good job we
got it so I think that means something I
don't know I don't think it does it
might I think it I think you just said
he's gonna take it out I think he's
gonna give you the Woody Allen but Woody
alligator I don't want to say when Woody
Allen was directing me I thought the
same thing after that we're pretty good
it's not coming out for a long time yeah
but I'll just say that at the end of the
you know during the scene he would come
up to me goes I don't know what you're
doing that's you know how many times I
heard this yeah I'll explain acting care
if you ever want because what is it
because I think I'm doing it well but
it's directors I think they're the
problem
these people I'll tell you exactly what
he cares I'm going to tell you exactly
what it is okay it's one we don't know
what we're doing with acting so it took
me a long time to understand yeah I
don't get it the problem yeah I do some
of it I get no no you're surprised I
show up
that's not enough here's what I'm
telling you the problem is when as
comedians in my opinion we try we want
to entertain in the scene so instead of
just realizing that Tim Dillon just
talking right here being yourself not
moving not trying to be entertaining is
funny what you understand on stage if
you went up there and you go haha I have
a joke and start laughing it would be
insane right but we're doing that in
acting scene she's like I have to be
interesting no you don't all you have to
do is just be yourself and that's fake
circumstance that's interesting and
that's funny and that's interesting
dangerous but it's because we're like I
gotta bring something to this that's the
opposite of what we know to be the truth
but because it's acting we think it's
got to be doing so I hope the scene is
in the movie yeah that is my hope and
prayer because in the end well at the
end I think it was great well when he
said we got it I think he means we get
it well no I I said to him I said was it
good he goes yay because I don't move on
until I got it because you got it
because and then a little Asian woman
came up to me and she goes uh he said
great job and I said thank you God it
sounds like you were badgering them and
then I left and then they never had me
back to set first of all the fact you go
was it good I think I felt cornered no
I'm six foot two oh I'm insane 62 irish
guys a little guy he was always here
that's what I mean and you're like was
it good he's like we got it please tell
him it's good first scene I did anyway
no Colin it's the first scene I did in
any movie who cares about some [__] it's
any movie and I'm not saying which movie
it was we'll do all movies what what
well I'm I don't think I'm allowed to
say it but I will say that
I hope it's in this movie because I
signed all this [__] it's like a Marvel
movie no it's like one of those type of
movies big movies it's a it's a it's a
it's a the stuff can I say the stars of
the movie can I say the stars of the
movie where'd you sign this I don't know
I don't read what I signed can I say the
stars of the movie but no I don't think
anyone will get it you talking to me
like I'm a I'm an entertainment lawyer I
don't know if you can say the stars of
the goddamn movie
he probably cut out anyway do you have a
close if you Colin they didn't cut it
out it's an integral scene that's what
he said yeah he goes and says I don't
think it's cutting out yeah
but I can't I don't want to tell people
what it is I here's what I'll say okay
the stars of the movie yeah
are
it's gonna oh they're big they're big
you I wonder if I say them will you get
it
um yeah I already get it White Men Can't
Jump the new one it is it is white man
can't John that's the Stars no it's
frozen three it's live action
let it go it's me and Dylan Mulvaney in
Frozen three
no it's it's the stars of the film are
are are Joaquin Phoenix and Lady Gaga
they're the stars of the movie and I'm
not gonna say the movie it starts in the
movie and the scene I had was with
Joaquin that's a big that's a big thing
it's very intimidating she's he's a
serious actor well so am I yeah a little
bit
and he was we both did well but no I I'm
hoping it's in I pray it's in because it
was really an amazing experience and I
pray it's him did you meet Lady Gaga no
no no no I you know
I think she's a brilliantly talented
person but I was super intimidated
because it was hard you know when you do
a scene with a guy like that it's tough
only because he's brilliant and you know
I did good
I think it's in don't you think it's him
no it sounds like it's out
just the fact that the guy that you had
to come over and go okay was that good
and he goes um yeah I only said is that
good because they had to keep doing it
he was screaming at me yeah saying it's
bad
yeah exactly
that's because it was a lot of blocking
that's what I was [__] up [__] and
the lines and the lines I couldn't oh
okay I didn't really have the line you
didn't feel like
uh self-conscious but other than the
blocking and the lines it was good
those were the two problems those are
the two those are not those those are
the those are the main issues those are
not important but they gave me the lines
of the day of because they didn't want
the script leaking out because it's one
of these films and was walking Phoenix
looking at you like who is this person
well he you know no no I think he gets
it yeah
I think he understood that we're
colleagues you should have asked him to
come on the podcast
I don't know how that would go Lady Gaga
he I don't know how that would go either
should be interesting Joaquin is
brilliantly in a you know he's so in it
yes that I don't know I don't know like
shooting the [__] how that
this this thing I do is what they
consider a low art form a low low art
what comedy and podcasts well just
sitting around and running my fat mouth
about things like it's not respected
you know what I mean it's like it's the
definition of not respected like there's
a great scene in Barry the new season of
Barry where they're like listen let me
explain something to you they're like
you called someone a [__] on the
internet and your boyfriend is in jail
for murder they're like you could have a
reality show or a podcast but
um but yeah it's it's tide is turned but
the reality is I I think probably people
look down on a podcast which I get if I
was walking Phoenix I may look down on a
podcast too
but I'm not
but I feel like the scene was really
good and I hope it's in it I don't want
to prep please don't get me in trouble
for saying the goddamn thing
I mean I say it I didn't say it they
could be doing five movies ten movies
wow
what's the big deal
I'm just saying the scenes in and I did
good
at the end it was good right
I just want you to believe it's good I
don't I I believe you got the same
reaction that I got from Woody Allen and
I got cut immediately but what do these
people know but all I know is you know
right now in your gut whether that's you
got God or not I just want to know
before I go because I'll be so
embarrassed
I'll be so embarrassed if it's not in I
know I'll be mortified yeah but usually
I think you find out beforehand that's
part of the your agent will find out I
think by the end of the yelling it was
actually good by the end of the the
screaming yeah because I got better well
yes I need to get roughed up a little
bit sometimes all right then that's good
because I needed that then that yeah
that made it worse after all of like
what the [__] are you doing why are you
doing it this way I don't understand
that why aren't you listening some
people like uh like um Quinn Buckner
responded to Bobby Knight's coaching but
Larry Bird left after a year because he
doesn't respond to that so some people
like to get yelled at by Bobby Knight
and some people leave the and go to
Indiana State because they can't take it
it all depends
I'm known as Hollywood's Larry Bird no
no you're the opposite you stood there
you're the guy that let's I'm no
Millennial you can spit in my face
that's what I'm saying me yeah just put
the scene in the movie yeah I'd respond
to someone because I need direct
everybody needs directions that's right
but you have the right attitude which is
like all right fine
David O Russell's of the world I could
get yelled at because I get it yes
because I am [__] it up a little bit
but maybe it's the whole process is
becoming better yeah well maybe maybe my
[__] up is like bringing things out
in all the other actors you're a great
enlightened attitude that's great I
think so yeah so maybe Joaquin was very
nice he put his hand on my shoulder and
he uh he uh pulled a lighter out of my
pocket you just started smoking oh what
have you seen oh yeah he well he smokes
on this on set because it helps him but
did you in the scene is he smoking a
cigarette no no I thought that was like
a cool thing in the middle of the scene
he took a lighter right now no no no to
his character you know well they kept
interrupting it going cut cut cut cut
yeah it listen by the end it was good
everything else is a process
colinquinn.com yes harlequin.com